[Music]
the spirit of this world is a spiritual
essence that is permeated by a
self-consciousness which knows itself
and knows the essence as in the
actuality confronting it but the
existence of this world is also the
actuality of self consciousness rests on
the process in which the latter divest
itself of its personality thereby
creating its world this world that looks
on as something Hailie in a world
therefore of which it must now take
possession but the renunciation of its
being for self is itself the product of
the actual world and by this
renunciation therefore
self-consciousness directly takes
possession of this world where we may
say that self-consciousness is merely as
something it has actuality only insofar
as it alienates itself from itself my
son doing it gives itself the character
of a universal and this its universality
is its authentication and actuality this
equality with everyone is therefore not
the Equality of the sphere of legal
right not that immediate recognition and
validity of self-consciousness simply
because it is on the contrary to be
valid it must have conformed itself to
the universal by the mediating process
of alienation the non spiritual
universality of the sphere of legal
writing so it's every natural form of
character as well as of existence and
justifies them the universality which
counts here however is one that has made
itself what it is and for that reason is
actual
Hegel begins this new section culture
and it's realm of actuality building and
Vere Clea kite in paragraph 488 with a
lot of rather abstract ways of talking
about things he says the spirit of this
world what is this world the spirit of
this this higher world is a spiritual
essence that is permeated by a
self-consciousness which knows itself
and knows the essence as an actuality
confronting it and that's kind of a nice
wrap up and that's actually not going to
be that important at this point I would
say that the second sentence is is much
more important he says the existence of
this world is also the actuality the
vehicle account that the determinacy of
self-consciousness rests on a process in
which self-consciousness divest itself
of its personality of you might say it's
as we're gonna see in paragraphs you
have to come it's purely naturalness of
its idiosyncrasies there is a a sort of
disciplining of the the self in
self-consciousness that is taking place
here and that's part of building of
culture so what is Hegel sketching out
here for us now we get to the stuff
that's really much more important he
talks about a double movement taking
place that involves a sort of
renunciation of oneself or aspects of
oneself and that allows at the same time
a taking possession that
self-consciousness is after that's one
side of the movement it's already
doubled there the other side of the
movement is that a world is being
projected or constructed to which
self-consciousness is subordinating
itself in order
to take something back from it so it
almost reads as if this is a sort of
projective process in which
self-consciousness is making for itself
it's its understanding of the world that
it inhabits because obviously it exists
in a world a world of others but it
constructs the world that it finds
itself in at least insofar as it
understands that world and can then
thereby see it as something to which it
must sacrifice aspects of itself in
order to gain something in the process
so these two sides go together let's
look now at what Hegel actually says
here so he says the world it looks on as
something alien a world therefore of
which it must now take possession right
but the renunciation of its being for
self is itself the product of the actual
world and by this renunciation
self-consciousness directly takes
possession of the world so it's you know
it looks like it's losing something
namely it's being for self what is it's
being for self its capacity to to judge
itself to say what it is it is it is
allowing the world to say that for it
but in doing so it gains a place it has
a seat at the table as we say it's
earned a certain right and we've seen
this playing itself out so many times
I'll give you an example and I don't
want to take us too far off course
because I do want to come back to the
text but think about when you begin a
job particularly a job that many many
other people work at and have worked at
and probably will work at after you
leave that job so for example I I worked
on a machine called the blaster in a
factory making aluminum die cast cam
covers oil pans that
they're car parts back when I was in
college and when you go into a place
like that you have to you know you learn
what the routines are you learn what the
order of the world is right so for
example that again just / from my own
personal experience one of the very
first things that we would do is go
through these giant barrels full of
gloves every shift because you wanted to
have a couple good gloves because you
otherwise your hands are gonna get torn
to ribbons by the pieces that you are
working with none of these pieces of
metal right and I learned that lesson
very quickly you need several pairs of
gloves and you better find ones that
really fit your hands well so you know
you can like try to be unique or do your
own thing and situations like that it's
not going to work out for you if you're
doing your own thing you really need to
as we say get with the program once you
do that that opens up doors for you that
opens up possibilities for you you you
start to understand in this case the
workings of the process that you're
involved with you you gain you know the
capacity to get in the right rhythm I
mean we could go on and on and there's
many many other kinds of examples of
building or culture that would fit in
here so he goes on and he says here we
go we may also say that
self-consciousness is merely a something
or it has actuality only insofar as it
alienates itself from itself
it becomes other to itself it allows
itself to be made into a thing precisely
so I can have that world for itself
now Hegel here is going to talk about
this as a process of realizing a
universal of making oneself into you
know universal and he's going to
contrast this with what is just going on
in the section on legal right so he says
in so doing it gives itself the
character of a universal again if we
want to use this factory worker example
you're no longer just Joe Schmo who came
in last week and it's kind of clumsy on
the blaster you're now effectively in a
particular sense of cog in the machine
right
you're one part of the grid the vast
working of the factory but you're also
the worker you are the one making the
blaster do what it ought to do and we
can come up with all sorts of other
examples that could perhaps tie in with
with things that we consider them closer
to culture than industrial processes
when we do that sort of thing
we're occupying the role of a universal
let's think for an example of the case
of being a professor right now it's
interesting in the old days when people
were more formal I suppose you could say
this was kind of a uniform although this
would be a little bit jaunty right black
and red bang and then the you know the
jacket and stuff away right it was kind
of a uniform for for not just academic
work but but people who were dressy in
general right people would wear jacket
and tie to go have dinner to go to a
movie theater to go to fly on an
airplane even people in lower middle
class would do that sort of thing now
it's got a different connotation and you
know you could you could ask yourself
well why why don't you just be like
those other professors who you know wear
a polo shirt or you know wear a t-shirt
or dress like a hipster for their
students and we can say well there's a
different kind of universal there isn't
it but it's all really the same sort of
thing you know you can you can be
expressing yourself and and all that
wonderful stuff but for the most part
you're really acting in a role here's
wearing a different kind of uniform
right as well hipster ism is kind of a
diminishing return at least from what
we're talking about here so Hegel says
this its universality is its
authentication in actuality now here he
talks about equality says this equality
with everyone is therefore not the
Equality of the sphere of legal right
not that immediate recognition and
validity of self-consciousness simply
because it is legal right gives
everybody the same status as equally
alienated because they are oh you get a
you know fog a mirror or be human or or
perhaps occupy certain social role right
with this Hegel says here what's
different is the person is making him or
herself that is what is giving them this
equality he says the universe out that
he says the non spiritual universality
the sphere of legal right accept every
natural form of character as well as
existence and justifies them they're all
fine you know you want to be that way
you want to be that way you want to be
that way that's all fine we'll just
treat you all the same hearing says the
universality which counts here is one
that he has made its is one that has
made itself what it is and for that
reason is actual not just formal not
just ideal but actual there's there's a
process of self making taking place here
it is therefore through culture that the
individual acquires standing in
actuality his true original nature and
substance is the alienation of himself
as spirit from his natural being this
externalization is therefore both the
purpose and the existence of the
individual it is at once the means or
the transition both of the mere thought
form of substance into actuality and
conversely of the specific individuality
into essentiality this individuality
molds itself by culture into what an
idiot trinsic li is and only by so doing
is it an intrinsic being that has an
actual existence the measure of its
culture is the measurement sexuality and
power although here the self knows
itself as this self yet its actuality
consists solely in the setting aside of
its natural self consequently the
originally specific nature is reduced to
the unofficial difference of quantity to
a greater or lesser energy and will but
the purpose and content of the will
belongs solely to the universal
substance itself and can only be a
universal the particularity of a nature
which becomes purpose and content is
something powerless and not real it is a
kind of being which vainly and
ridiculously strains every nerve to get
going it is a contradiction of giving to
what is particular in actuality which is
immediately a universal if therefore
individuality is erroneously supposed to
be rooted in the particularity of nature
and character than in the actual world
there are no individuality and no
characters but everyone is like everyone
else but this presumed individuality
really only exists in someone's mind an
imaginary existence which has no abiding
place in this world where only that
which externalizes itself and therefore
only the universal obtained obtains an
actual existence then is why such an
imagined existence is esteemed for what
it is for a kind of being kind is not
quite the same as asbestos and all
nicknames for it denotes mediocrity and
this expresses the highest degree of
contempt kind and good
it's kind are however German expressions
which adhere of honesty to the meaning
as if it were not really met so badly or
again consciousness is in fact not yet
aware what kind and what culture and
reality are
paragraph 489 is a very interesting
passage there there's a lot going on
here
that we want to unpack much of it is is
sort of at the level of the text we
don't have to dive too deep and I don't
even think we need to come up with too
many examples at this point in order to
grasp what he's saying and there's
really two movements in in this this
paragraph there's an initial movement
where we're talking about you know how
the individual essentially I mean I'm
gonna use just the cognate here builds
himself
Miller has molds him or herself through
through culture right
the culturing is the molding we'll get
to that in a moment and then the second
part is about how people you may you
might say insist
too much on their particularities and
find that it just kind of slips away
that it doesn't it doesn't mean all that
much that hey we're all unique we're all
you know makers or you know DIY people
or artists or whatever you like right
and none of it means anything so what
we've really got here are two different
understandings of the human being that
Hegel is not actually disentangling from
each other but which we can identify
here in this this passage so let's take
a look at what the text is telling us so
he says it's through culture through
building that the individual acquires
standing and actuality through this
process of making oneself into a
universal now notice what he's going to
say here this is really really
interesting his true original nature the
bromley cannot to her and substance is
the alienation of himself as spirit from
what from his natural being naturally
his signs
so we have two different senses of
nature here right
nature's being used in two different
ways
original nature natural being our
natural being is the stuff that we
typically think of as our our nature the
particularities and our original nature
is something that we have to work to
bring out it's not something there on
the surface so if I say for example I'm
an irascible person which is true you
know I mean thinking back over my
history reason why I'm so interested in
researching anger in the first place
finding remedies in philosophy maybe
that's not what my true nature is maybe
my true nature is what I am at the
process after I've learned to understand
and manage and lessen and turn to better
uses that ear ask ability I've already
given you one example right there I
didn't mean to give examples well let's
let's go on so he says this
externalization is therefore both the
purpose and the existence of the
individual it is at once the means or
the transition both of the mere thought
form of substance into actuality and
conversely of the specific individuality
into essentiality so what's going on
here the individual does not find who or
what she really is at the core he or she
by looking merely at their natural being
not for example gender he or she looked
down what genitals do you have well
there's your destiny no it depends so
much on what you make of them or of
anything else that you've been endowed
with right this is where so many kids go
go bad by the way
not in terms of sexuality but in terms
of intelligence especially smart kids
they have a certain facility they get
some tests that tell them that they're
in the 95th percentile they have
teachers telling them that they're
they're brilliant and they are brilliant
for fifth graders or twelfth graders and
then they get into much more difficult
situations where they needed to grow
they needed to develop they needed to
subordinate themselves they needed to
engage in somewhat Hegel is calling
alienation and externalization here or
you know another way of talking about it
is the building the culturing the
forming and shaping of oneself the
transitioning from mere particularity
into essentiality or universality and
they don't do it and it's tough for them
and they are that they're they're living
in their glory days the rest of their
life they're unable to conform
themselves to to learn something more so
the talent that they have goes to waste
so he goes on and he says this
individuality molds itself by culture
into what it intrinsically is now I've
put the German for that on the board
here because the German is actually much
more direct the individual build it
zigzoo dame vazhi on zyk is literally it
it shapes forms that bill it builds
itself it cultures itself it doesn't do
so by means of culture that is the
culturing it cultures itself into what
zoo dame vas see on the kiss what it is
in itself so the in itself here is not
just something that you're born with or
that you you have as a brute fact the in
itself is what you make of yourself what
you become what you reveal within
yourself through the process of engaging
in culture or self disciplining and
notice that there this is not just
somebody else coming along and imposing
it on you making you jump through the
hoops as we say imposing a lot of
exercises
at a certain point one takes ownership
over it and realizes that this is
actually for one's own good to develop
as the person one is so Hinkle goes on
and he says okay here we go the
individuality molds itself by culture
into what it intrinsically is only by so
doing is it an intrinsic being that has
an actual existence there's a beautiful
phrase right here the measure of its
culture is the measure of its actuality
and power insofar as it has engaged in
culture to that degree it has the
actuality of ear click height and power
mocked the capacity to do something in
the world ok so that is the first part
now notice what Hegel is going to say
after this he says here the self knows
itself as this self yet it's actuality
consists solely in the setting aside of
its natural soft bringing that to a
close consequently the originally
specific nature is reduced to the UH
necessity to a greater or lesser energy
of will but the purpose and content of
the will belong solely to the universal
substance itself and can only be a
universal when we talk about the will
we're already universalizing to a
certain degree but we are talking about
the particular individual so what else
is going to be said here he says here
now we're gonna have a long discussion
of how things are going going wrong for
it the particularity of a nature which
becomes purpose and content is something
powerless and unreal unreal and
powerless by comparison to this
Universal right it is a kind of being
which mainly and ridiculously strains
every nerve to get going it is a
contradiction of giving to what is
particular an actuality which is
immediately a universal again to use
examples let me use a one
from from artistry and we'll talk about
say the musical arts there's so many
unfortunate people who are told that
they are geniuses and so creative and
all of that and they don't want to learn
proper technique because technique is
boring technique is like what everybody
else is doing it's a universal right I'm
gonna do my own thing man I'm gonna be
original and then their originality
sounds pretty much like everybody else's
or it just sounds crappy and then they
wonder why they're not making any
progress as musicians so you say I don't
know are you doing exercises are you
playing scales are you playing other
people's songs no man I don't want to
you know influence my my my you know way
of seeing things and hearing things I
got to be Who I am well you know when
you're first developing you have no idea
who the hell you are you discover that
by supporting your subordinating
yourself through culture through
discipline to the universal that's what
frees you up this insistence on
particularity or we say uniqueness it's
really a trap so he says what we've got
here
if individuality is erroneously supposed
to be rooted in the particularities of
nature and character no notice what he
says here very interesting then in the
actual world the veer Clea felt there
are no individuality x' and no
characters everybody is like everybody
else
this presumed individuality really
exists only in someone's mind it's a
figment of one's imagination it's a
conceit he says it has an imaginary
existence which has no abiding place in
this world where only that which
externalizes itself and therefore only
the universal obtains an actual
existence now you can in this world you
can mediate that in
anyways you can do you're imagining
through social media you can do you're
imagining through a MySpace page
you can do you're imagining through you
know creating all sorts of interesting
sites but unless you're actually
externalizing something that requires
your subordination of your own
particularity or individuality there's
something greater than than just
yourself and your own will to be
different it has no actuality it has no
depth that has no weight it doesn't last
so he goes on any and he's you know he's
gonna get very biting he says that is
why such an imagined existence is
esteemed for what it is for a kind of
being kind is not quite the same thing
as especi all Nick names for it denotes
mediocrity and expresses the highest
degree of contempt he's getting this
Miller tells us from deuteros Ramos
nephew right which we can talk about
much later on he says kind and good of
its kind are however German expressions
which add an air of honesty to the
meaning as if it were not really meant
so badly or again consciousness is in
fact not yet aware of what kind and what
culture and reality are Hales saying
that if you're just a kind of thing you
know that you really you're not much of
anything at all now there's a difference
between being a kind of thing and being
the universal how does that play out
well we have to go a little bit further
to find that out